hey this is pressure Locker you have two
ropes and lighter these are special
ropes each rope burns in exactly 60
minutes the ropes however do not burn at
a constant rate so you don't know that
half the rope burns in 30 minutes or
that X percent of the rope burns an x
percent of the time the problem for you
is how can you measure 45 minutes by
burning the ropes now some of you may
have heard this problem so in this video
I'm going to pose a variation how can
you measure 50 minutes by burning the
ropes give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution so it takes a little bit of
ingenuity to measure 45 minutes I'm
going to explain the steps first and
then I'm going to show you how it works
in a little animation the key is we
start by lighting the ropes in three
different places
at the same time we'll light one end of
one rope and both ends of the other rope
the rope which has two flames is going
to burn two times as fast as it normally
would so it's going to burn up in 30
minutes at this point the other rope
will have 30 minutes remaining on it so
you then light the other end of that
rope and that will give you a rope which
is burning two times as fast as it
normally would so that remaining rope
will burn up in 15 minutes
so if you add up to 30 minutes and the
15 minutes you get a total of 45 minutes
from start to end so let's see how this
works we start by lighting the ropes in
three places we light one end of one
rope and both ends of the other rope now
we'll let the flames go the rope which
had two flames on it is going to burn
two times as fast so at that point
thirty minutes have elapsed at exactly
that moment you want to start a flame at
the other end of the other rope so this
rope which should burn in 30 minutes
with a single flame will now burn two
times as fast because it has two flames
so this rope will
burning in 15 minutes 30 plus 15 gets
you 45 minutes from start to end
so now let's tackle the next problem how
can we measure 50 minutes we already
know how to measure 30 minutes we light
one rope at both ends this rope will
burn up in 30 minutes so the question is
how do we measure 20 minutes the key is
that if one row burns in 30 minutes when
it has two flames the same rope will
burn in 20 minutes when it has three
flames going so how are we going to get
three flames going well we're going to
use a little trick we're going to like
the rope at one end and we're also going
to light it somewhere in the middle the
flame in the middle is actually going to
split off in both directions so that's
how you're going to end up getting three
flames on this rope so this rope which
would burn in 60 minutes with a single
flame is now going to burn in one-third
the time it's going to burn in 20
minutes with three flames now two of the
flames may end up meeting and I'm going
to show you what to do in that case you
actually just like the rope in another
spot but if you do this correctly you're
going to measure 20 minutes and then 30
plus 20 is equal to 50 so let's see how
this works so we start by lighting one
rope at both of its ends we already know
how to do this this is going to measure
30 minutes exactly when this rope burns
out you want to light the other rope in
two different places you light it at one
end and then you light it somewhere in
the middle so three flames are going to
come from that now if what I showed you
just happened where you have two of the
flames meeting you're only going to end
up with one flame remaining on the rope
so what you then do is you repeat this
by lighting this somewhere in the middle
now that middle flame is going to split
off into flames so you keep on lighting
the rope so that you always have three
flames going if you do this in the limit
you're going to measure that this rope
is going to burn three times as fast so
it's going to burn in 20
minutes and therefore you have 30 plus
20 which equals 50 minutes did you
figure it out thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch one on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker I liked the video please check
out my books their links in the video
description